first take least almost every day there
are new revelations about awarding the
2006 fifa world cup to germany yet stock
my Freitag social democrats politician
and head of the Sports Committee in the
Bundestag says now all the facts must be
put on the table she's our guest this
week hello hello hello to you head CT
would come and welcome to the DW
interview I'm Alexandra phenomena
Freitag when you think about the 2006
world cup here in Germany does a
personal experience come to mind
immediately and that's the Sephora enum
yeah undisputed yes the match against
Argentina it was fabulous one of the
highlights and of course I remember the
millions of enthusiastic people in our
country the summer fairy tale was a
summer fairy tale regardless of what
we're discussing now and it remains one
what's despite the revelations I'm not
released yes of course the gossip on
people's enthusiasm and hospitality
which reached far beyond our country's
borders will remain what we're
discussing now is unpleasant and also
very damaging both for the reputation of
the german football association and also
for the reputation of the sport but you
have to separate the one from the other
we delivered a wonderful image as good
hosts to the public and no discussion
can or should take that away from us the
Stefan's off kinda discuss your name a
teensy DeMars 5006 back in two thousand
six would you have ever thought there
was something not right about the
successful World Cup vid by finding and
for the ganas nine happy know to be
honest I didn't because I simply assume
that when Germany bids to host that kind
of championship we host many
international events in Germany the
organizers would comply with legal
criteria that's open affect our kitchen
criterion boyfriend however that's nice
night wasn't that naive goalkeeping
legend Seth Meyer was quoted as saying
with FIFA you never get a world cup
without greasing palms what do you think
of that statement Minecon is my evening
when comes you can call it naive
you can also see it differently Germany
gave government guarantees in advance of
its bid that is among other things there
were tax concessions Germany waived tax
revenues so I have to say as a
government representative but I have to
expect our football associations to act
according to reasonable criteria zip
about V Z and Z do all of how do you see
the role of Franz Beckenbauer who headed
the organizing committee for the 2006
world cup and is now considered a key
figure in the affair went example of
farragut as it's miss Gilchrist I did
not really have to inspect ambala Oh
first it must be said that Franz
Beckenbauer has made endless
contributions to german football but and
welcomes the but in my view that doesn't
excuse him from the duty of doing his
part to clear up the Safari his
worldwide reputation alone isn't enough
to allow him to remain silent now he
could perform a further service for
German soccer but quickly and clearly
laying his cards on the table Merkel
external ausstellung concede aside
indeed of what do you think of the DF
B's current attempts at clarifications
of the clan the set aside time will tell
I've always demanded that government
investigators should intervene whenever
possible and now that's happened tax
investigation authorities are also
interested in the affair for gunk Heyman
had seen it seems it took a tax
investigation to get the inquiry rolling
the Pennzoil and the of Clarence want
something that's what I've been saying
for a long time I have great doubts that
sporting bodies can clean up their act
on their own there are ethics
commissions and certain committees but
it's doubtful whether they have the
necessary power given that as in the
present case former dfb president
Wolfgang neo spa was himself under
investigation yet he's the one who hired
the law firm to conduct the
investigations such conflicts are almost
impossible to resolve which is why it's
good that government bodies are dealing
with his two does he study first and
ultimately chef to them
this up any sawdust cadet but don't you
think politicians bear some
responsibility too after all it's not
just sporting bodies the profit from
hosting an event like the World Cup
businesses and politicians do to what it
seek so maybe I didn't one look too
closely at how Germany came to be
awarded the event is a spot events at
safety class yet hey as a messenger you
have to differentiate between the
operation of the sporting bodies and the
government's duties I know members of
the government were also on supervisory
committees at the time but generally
supervisory bodies can only assess
what's submitted to them where possible
under the table deals are concerned
there's also the accusation of slush
funds you can be pretty sure government
officials weren't officially informed at
least that's what I assume as follows
I'm happy but shouldn't you look more
closely the fog is a woman a question is
always where can you look more closely
this wasn't a government bid it was a
bit by an autonomous German sports body
and you have to separate the two of
course the bid wasn't made without
political activity the politic naturally
occurring but give the South me but
aren't relations between professional
sports and politics generally too cozy
when politicians are there cheering in
the stadiums it's when after a game they
might go into the locker room to
celebrate the victory he'll want a
genome it's tough I am they are just
come talk about that depends on how
politicians themselves deal with the
situation there's nothing wrong with
having good contacts to organized sports
but we ourselves are responsible for how
we deal with those good contacts and the
relationships we have with individual
sport body representatives that fate and
ever been in my view we have to keep the
two worlds separate and as politicians
we must always be conscious of that even
if we enjoy visiting the locker room
like Chancellor Merkel indica be negate
the Deacons for it there's even of
materials but you were also with the
Chancellor at the world cup final in
Brazil meisterschaft in Brazil yeah but
not in the locker room misty sounds
right but you were at the match yet you
still believe there's enough distance
between professional sports and politics
thus as least souvenirs
it's important that you can listen
conceived no longer I can only say again
that we're responsible for how we deal
with each situation we also speak to
representatives of other organizations
it's not limited to sports it's our job
to retain our power of discrimination no
one can do that for us we have to decide
for ourselves that's and tried yeah man
my exact you once said sport was a
constant theme running through your life
how did that start I'm fine wit from
sexy at age five or six in a traditional
gymnastics club in my hometown of let
mutter which is now part of a larger
town is alone so I basically had a
typical childhood experience of sports
going to gymnastics club and finding out
what I enjoyed most my son's plasma and
what did you enjoy most yes my good mech
first move at first I found out what I
didn't enjoy it all that was gymnastics
but then I found I could run fairly fast
if I'd had the opportunity I'd have
played football but at the time there
were no girls football teams so with my
nimble legs I ended up in athletics and
later volleyball those ended up being my
favorite sports was mine by Denis
pinkrod salmon all sport you then also
studied sports but became a teacher why
boom-lay up fights nadama cuz it was fun
back then I was good at it and I always
think it's sensible in life to do what
you can do best and con what sports and
athletics have a company of my life
right up to the present day I can really
get rich money even good soul yeah visit
the store now do you even have time to
exercise with your stressful routine
students just a second I attack as we
hear in bending not here in Berlin but
it's partly my fault if I got up an hour
earlier it would be possible but sadly
I'm not someone who goes jogging at 6am
dragon gate and couldnt isn't oh you're
also vice president of the German
Athletics Association that sport has
been hit by scandals time and again
that's what outfit mi vida funds come
down the current scandal is about doping
on a grand scale at the 2012 summer
olympics in london and the 2014 winter
olympics in sochi in your eyes can
competitive sports still serve as a role
model for young people I hope no for be
attractive for you and I mentioned
yeah I think yes I think so it's
important to make a commitment to clean
up sports the German Athletics
Association has been advocating
anti-doping legislation in Germany which
by the way will come and you can also
achieve something in an organization by
raising your voice I do that understand
i heaped on destroy you that's
anti-doping cuz its endorsed anti-doping
legislation will come to Germany but it
has taken a long time and there's been
plenty of resistance comes Iman's smile
were you sometimes under pressure from
lobbyists who oppose the legislation
that's cuz that's fine yeah Monbiot
wrong yes you do become a bit of an
outcast in the system when you take a
stand against a majority opinion but
when in doubt you have to hold out if
you're convinced you're right about like
this I was and I am and you see I held
out and Germany will get anti-doping
legislation and I hope that becomes an
example for other countries under the
linda hubbard avoid us could see even
though there's criticism that the final
version was slightly watered down Jesus
dopey anti-doping Gazette's yeah the
hottest nor off dirty girl yes towards
the end there were one or two attempts
and conservative MPs tried partly I
imagine at the request of sports
organizations to add certain provisions
to the legislation they don't harm it
much I thought what was done was
completely unnecessary especially I'd so
feel it happens for forever but i
believe we shouldn't give potential
dopers a chance to save face one kind of
Goldman quitting bone see van yet soccer
stuff way no they can also be legally
prosecuted that's that's the most
progressive part of the law wouldn't you
say yeah not really yes of course now
athletes who don't let those who
ultimately benefit from doping can be
investigated by public prosecutors that
doesn't oppose what sports law can do
athletes will continue to face a doping
ban if they provide a positive sample
but if they're in possession of
substances that could be misused for
doping purposes they can now also be
prosecuted by the state and I think
that's right Ian on to decide
refurbished issue
doesn't knock the S they're also the
first woman to be elected chair of the
German government Sports Committee was
that something special at the time and
is it still now vodice must bazan
another study some type of an eyesore
was completely normal or shawn gann snow
mile at the Heart is a snitch smell but
today it's nothing special anymore back
in two thousand nine it didn't pass
unnoticed that after more than 40 years
in existence the bundestag Sports
Committee was now headed by a woman but
I'd say the men have gotten used to it
social studies in to close off the
interview as always we start three
sentences and ask you to finish them
forms it is advised that cellphone sue
for and the next time I meet Franz
Beckenbauer hands Beckenbauer tougher
done and good eating I'd say to him how
good that you've helped to clear up this
affair you performed a service to the
dfb I won't evolve that's how buddy
hasn't done that yet but but it's what
I'd like to be able to say to him then I
knew when a teen asked me whether they
should do competitive sports I say yeah
yes but remember that your performance
is the result of your talent and how
hard you train it's your own individual
accomplishment and you must be happy
with its atomic mass of readings on
Anthony said if I become a competitive
athlete myself then done that might help
fulfilled a big dream because I want it
to be as good as high dolls and doll but
unfortunately it didn't work out look
both quite a crowd right thank you my
pleasure